so that was before 9 11 way before 9 11
that's when you realize okay this was
the truth and what really interested you
from the get-go was the Oneness that
tohee the pure monotheism definitely you
know many Christians struggle with that
you know people in our you know in who
are viewing us who aren't here right now
but people out there you know I talk to
a lot of Christians and there was a new
study that came out that half of
Christians 30 of even evangelicals
believe that Jesus is not God that's a
deep struggle from within you know what
I mean and here you go and you being a
Christian you come across Islam the
truth and now you're exposed to it and
you don't cover it up